[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
from the olympics to an attempted murder
trial how defendant michael barissone
reacted moments after a near deadly
shooting i just appeared impartial
not excited not upset not angry just
sitting there and i was able
i was able to hold my father's hand as
he
took his last breath the state wrecks
his case as ex-icu doctor william
hussell stands trial for patient murder
plus the deadly waukesha christmas
parade we all recognize there could be a
problem
in handling the jury from waukesha
county how both sides work to seat an
impartial juror but first do you think
i'm playing with you
you're wrong man i'm a grown man
i don't like what you did
disturbing video shows life inside the
sarah lawrence college cult law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the prosecution's exhibits are
showing more about what went on behind
the curtain of the sarah lawrence sex
cult as the group's alleged leader
lawrence ray stands trial on federal
charges
ray is facing several federal charges
including racketeering sex trafficking
and money laundering among others it all
stems from rey allegedly starting the
rey family after he moved in with his
daughter's tally as on-campus housing at
sarah lawrence college back in 2010.
over the next 10 years ray allegedly
used manipulation and fear tactics to
gain control of talia's college friends
his alleged victims initially saw rey as
a father figure but those who have
testified so far say they soon saw a
different side of him cameras aren't
allowed in federal court but several
publicly released court exhibits are
giving more insight to the testimony and
what happened over the last 10 years
including a rare one showing rey
allegedly using violence against daniel
levin one of rey's alleged victims who
also wrote a memoir about his time as a
rave family cult member
so you're trying to pull back now aren't
you
yeah
no i don't know
i did the comment stuff like
back around the time of like the
mitt romney blog like way back like
months ago trying to march again wanting
to meet them being honest
do you understand see this how it feels
what if i pick you up like that i'm
people up by you
huh
do you think i'm playing with you
you're wrong man i'm a wrong man
i don't like what you did
[Music]
you hear me
now one more time and i want to put your
tongue in here you understand me
no
yeah yes
you don't start telling truth i spent
good money to find out these facts you
little pieces
and i'm telling you listen to me
listen to me
don't fuck around with
lying now
tell the truth
next thing's gonna be out of your
fucking balls
did you like that the other night when
your balls were getting strangulated no
huh what should i do to them tonight
law and crimes adam classville is
spending the duration of this trial
inside the courtroom he has details on
tuesday's continued testimony from
another one of ray's alleged victims
felicia rosario
felicia rosario's testimony has just
started into cross-examination
at the in the direct examination
concluded this morning with a
bit of a surprising allegation
that goes to the money laundering count
the government claims that
some of the enterprise money from larry
ray's alleged criminal enterprise
went through
to rosario who in turn donated it to
larry's daughter
talia ray
who at the time was working for the
north carolina democratic party so they
are essentially the government is
alleging
that this money uh passed through
through political donations so that was
the end of direct examination we're
starting to get into the world of
cross-examination
we don't know how much longer felicia
rosario will be on the witness stand
or whether other victims are going to
testify after her
we have heard the name throughout the
trial for example dan levin
we're not sure whether or not he will
take the stand but we have seen and
heard much about him throughout this
trial
it has been quite a journey for many of
them
to go from his orbit to a federal court
witness stand
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney taylor coss and terry austin to
break down the latest in the lawrence
wray sex cult federal trial taylor money
transferring over state lines connected
through political donations does rosario
give the government everything they need
for the money laundering charge
you know it's interesting that we're
talking about money laundering after we
see those highly disturbing videos of
what went on at sarah lawrence and and
the years after um you know the array of
charges against ray are troubling and
and seem to be far more serious than
money laundering however having said
that i think it is interesting this
development um that that felicia was
essentially taking profits from the
criminal enterprise and funneling them
down to the north carolina democratic
party via uh rey's daughter and so i
think her testimony is key and essential
to the money laundering laundering
charges and i doubt
uh that without her testimony those
charges would ever have been brought
against him so she is certainly the
linchpin uh with regards to those
specific charges absolutely now terry do
you get a sense the prosecution's case
is coming to an end also my guess is ray
never takes the stand i think he'd be
absolutely destroyed on
cross-examination what do you think
he'll do
listen i think the jury's hoping the
case comes to an end it's been several
weeks already and we've had several
witnesses who were victims and their
testimony has been riveting and as we've
been talking about these videos are so
damaging and very difficult to listen to
so i am certain the jury does not want
to see more of that as far as whether or
not the defendant lawrence ray is going
to take the stand i cannot imagine of
all cases this is the very case where he
should not take the stand there is
absolutely no way he can explain what
goes on in those videos
all right we'll see how it continues as
we get more from adam classville to
updates in that case switching now to
south carolina where disgraced attorney
alec murdoch confesses to scamming the
family of his late housekeeper out of
millions of dollars in an insurance
payout murdoch now admits he swindled
the family of his housekeeper gloria
stattersfeld who died on his family
property back in 2018. at the time
murdoch suggested satterfeld's son sue
him for insurance money to create a
greater payout starterfeld's family says
they never received that money and
murdoch now admits he kept it for
himself he's now asking the court to
uphold the order to pay back the
statterfelds family 4.3 million dollars
all this is just the latest twist in the
so-called murdoch murder mystery murdoch
made national headlines in june of last
year when his wife maggie and son paul
were found murdered on the family's
property months later murdoch confessed
to orchestrating a botched suicide for
hire plan in hopes of leaving a life
insurance policy to his remaining son
and in national news of federal judge
rules that former president donald trump
most likely committed felonies in an
attempt to overturn the 2020 election
trump's lawyer john eastman is now
ordered to turn over documents that have
been withheld from the january 6
committee trump and eastman are accused
of obstructing the work of congress and
conspiracy to defraud the united states
this as white house records from january
6 are turned over to the house select
committee showing a nearly eight-hour
gap in trump's call log that means there
are no records of the calls made by
trump during the insurrection of the u.s
capitol the house committee is now
investigating whether trump communicated
via back channels or burner phones
during that time
still ahead on law and crime daily after
weeks of witness testimony the state
rests its case in ohio versus william
hussell but first the deadly crash at
the waukesha holiday parade is it
possible to seat an impartial jury
[Music]
welcome back the man charged with
crashing his vehicle into a wisconsin
christmas parade appears in court on
tuesday as both sides work to secure an
impartial jury for the upcoming trial
daryl brooks faces 83 charges in
connection to the november 2021 crash in
waukesha wisconsin prosecutors say
brooks crashed through barriers and
drove into the parade killing six people
and injuring dozens others
earlier this month a waukesha county
judge set a trial date for october
saying the months leading up to the
trial should be spent working to secure
an impartial jury prosecutors suggested
a jury questionnaire should be sent out
in april being that many people in the
county were either at the parade know
someone who was affected or donated to
support funds for those affected while
the defense motioned for a new venue and
indicated it would not be ready for an
october trial but the defense still
agreed with the judge and prosecutors
that a jury questionnaire should be sent
out in the next week
back with us it's criminal defense
attorney taylor cause and terry austin
as you look ahead to jury selection for
the deadly waukesha parade crash taylor
i doubt they can find an impartial jury
in waukesha but how far is far enough to
find an impartial jury in wisconsin
yeah brian in my opinion waukesha is a
total and complete non-starter they
there's no way they can get a a a fair
jury there this is small town usa
terrible terrible uh big huge incident
had the eyes on it from almost everyone
in town and somebody is connected so the
question becomes in this day and age how
far is far enough it used to be where
you could go to a town you know maybe 20
30 miles away and you'd be fine but with
the internet and 24-hour news cycle it
becomes harder and harder to find a fair
venue uh with regards to cases that are
the focus of the press so i would say on
something like this you need to go at
least two three four hours away to even
attempt to get a fair jury but this is
gonna be a struggle for them uh it's
gonna be tough yeah now terry can you
give us an example of the type of
questions brooks's defense may want for
a case like this in their questionnaire
well i think that questionnaire is going
to have to be detailed and it's going to
have to be clear because we know in
other juries it's not clear what you're
talking about and they're going to want
answers so for instance are you a victim
of a crime define what crime is so it's
very clear whether or not you were a
victim of a crime and i think the
defense is going to want to know that
because those people will be less
sympathetic on the flip side of that the
defense is going to want to know whether
or not you've been accused of a crime we
know for a fact that brooks has in the
past been accused and convicted of
various crimes so we want to know that
for the defense and then i think mental
illness that might be an issue here
they're going to want to know if anyone
has ever suffered any mental illness
yeah especially that last one because i
i'm still racking my brain to see what
the possible defense is going to be here
or if it says in part in the term just a
very slow plea towards the guilty
verdict but of course we'll give you
updates as this case eventually starts
probably months from now coming up on
law and crime daily a closer look at the
moments following the shooting of lauren
canarac we head to new jersey for the
olympian attempted murder trial plus the
state rests its case in the trial of
ex-icu doctor william hussell was it
murder or patient care
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
state rests its case in the trial for
former dr william hussell a former ohio
icu physician on trial for the murders
of over a dozen patients prosecutors
allege husel prescribed excessive
amounts of fentanyl to 14 of his
patients while they are being treated at
mount carmel hospital from 2015 to 2018.
his defense team argues he was simply
giving end-of-life comfort care
prosecutors called medical experts to
testify and who sells former co-workers
including pharmacists and nurses who
worked alongside the former doctor
prosecutors are also called family
members of who cell's alleged victims
sons and daughters among others who lost
a family member under his care many of
them testified about conversations with
whoso learning that their family member
was dying and having to make the
difficult decision to take them off of
life support the prosecution's final
witness was a son of a patient he lost
his father after complications from a
lesion on his foot and toe amputations
what did dr hughes will tell you
during this option
again he said that my father's organs
were shutting down the lactic acid was
building up in his body and that he was
potentially brain damaged or dead
uh
as the the situation never changed at
that point and uh it came to us later
and he said we might want to consider
removing off of the uh
the ventilators
later on in the evening i'd say probably
around eight o'clock uh
after dr youssef approached me we
we had a family meeting to decide
whether or not to remove him off of the
machines
and what information if anywhere you're
relying
uh for this family meeting whose
information are you relying on on the
information that dr youssel provided us
criminal defense attorney taylor cost
and co-host terry austin join us again
as the prosecutor rests and we look
ahead to what's next for who sells trial
terry the defense is going to ask for a
trial order dismissal it happens all the
time now that the prosecution is
arrested why do you think they'll lose
that motion
oh they will definitely lose those types
of motions are rarely granted by the
judge you have to prove that the
prosecution failed to produce enough
evidence or claim that the prosecution
failed to produce enough evidence to
support a guilty verdict but here
there's plenty of evidence they have
multiple witness they have multiple
experts who've all said that dr hussell
over-medicated and caused the death of
their family members but frankly brian i
think we have evidence on the other side
too so this is definitely one of those
cases that should go to a jury to
determine which side is more accurate
here i don't think it's going to be easy
though yep now taylor
why did he do this
this seems to be the major question
still left on the table in this trial do
you think whoso on the stand could lead
to an acquittal
so the only way we will ever know why
you know we know the what we know the
where we know the how the why can only
come from the doctor himself
i think he testifies and i think it's
probably the only way he has a chance of
an acquittal here because this is a case
that is just wrought with emotion uh the
situation that we just heard the witness
on the stand going through those last
emotional moments of a relative a family
member a loved one's life many many
people have gone through that and it's
likely that many members of the jury
have gone through that if the doctor
could get on the stand and explain that
during that
of the ultra most sensitive moments he
was only trying to ease uh the pain uh
of his patients and guide them to the
next portion of their life um perhaps
the jury uh will sympathize with that
and realize that this is not a criminal
just a doctor performing his duty yeah a
full acquittal is still a home run very
hard to get but
two or three jurors sympathizing with
the defense in this very difficult
decision i think he could actually have
a hung jury and maybe find him not
guilty in this case but of course we'll
keep eyes on this case as it develops
when we come back a one-time olympian is
now on trial for two counts of attempted
murder still ahead the first witness is
called in the state of new jersey first
michael berson
[Music]
welcome back we're getting a closer look
into the minor defendant michael
barrisson the one-time olympian now in
charge with two counts of attempted
murder a psychic evaluation release by
the defense says quote at the time of
the shooting barozone was severely
psychotic this echoes the defense's
opening statement on monday where
attorney edward belinkus told jurors
that his client had a history of abuse
and mental health issues prosecutors say
barristone annoyingly shot lauren
canorack back in 2019 and attempted to
shoot her boyfriend robert goodwin
leading up to the shooting canarac and
goodwin lived on verizon's property at
the same time barristone was training
counteract in dressage writing before
the shooting a string of 9-1-1 calls
were made by both parties barrosone
saying he tried to evict canorak and
kanarak saying she was being harassed
barriston was arrested after he shot
canorack in the chest and fired another
shot at goodwin as goodwin's struggle
with barrow's stone cannonrack called
9-1-1 on monday the prosecution called
his first witness a corporal who
responded to the 9-1-1 call and shooting
do you recall whether you overheard him
making any statements during the time
you were in his vicinity yes i did can
you tell the jury what you
heard those statements to be
i had a good life
now do you recall uh whether the
defendant said that once or more than
once uh multiple times maybe two or
three times
and you just said that he had he stated
i had a good life was that a verbatim
statement or is that a summary of what
you recall him saying that's what he
said
were those statements made in response
to any questioning by you no
can you describe the defendant's
appearance or demeanor at the time that
he was making these statements
i just appeared impartial um not excited
not upset not angry just
sitting there
did you have any issues understanding
the words that he used no
taylor in the prosecution's opening they
said the alleged victims in this case
can iraq and goodwin
may have done things the jurors may not
like
what do you think that could be and why
bring it up in openings
so you bring it up in the opening
because so if you know it's going to
happen and you know it's coming what you
want to do is you want to take the sting
out of it right away right from the
beginning no surprises no points for the
defense if you know that something
negative about your witness is going to
come out you want to be the one to be
the first to tell the jury now in this
case since they didn't mention any
specifics it seems to be that while they
think there might be some bad things
coming out they might not know a what
specific things are coming out or b what
rulings the court is going to make to
allow them to come back but we have
heard that barristone has reportedly
called the police several times tried to
have the victims evicted
victims evicted from the property and
also claimed that they threatened him
and attempted to damage his property so
it could be along the lines of some of
those things all right we'll see how the
testimony rolls out terry the defense
gave a fairly detailed opening statement
do you think he has planted seeds of
reasonable doubt so far
absolutely i listened to that
prosecution and i was thinking okay this
is a done deal i listened to the defense
and there is reasonable doubt that
opening was very detailed and in fact
taylor is talking about some of the
details that actually came out i think
they're going to claim you know both
self-defense and both mental illness and
they established during that opening
statement that he was being harassed by
lauren kinerick and that the
boyfriend was also
harassing him he called 9-1-1 four
different times he said he was in fear
of his life and then on a post she
actually said that he had sex with a
child so yes i think he
good defense all right we'll see as the
testament rolls in in this case thank
you both and thank you for joining us
here at law on crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you